hello and welcome to this video we eat
chess as my opponent
flayed him already three times losing
the first game yeah I kind of remember
that I did a bad screw up in this one
Bishop to before into thin air that's a
funny move really when a three is often
useful
bit odd so yeah I wonder if I can play
away that d5 isn't even possible you
know if I go Knight f3 he might still
have d5 about what about this kid just
go for blockade 26 it's really handy
that a3 is in because I move like before
and so it could be and so on could be
useful
so canceling long they're probably not
home rocked you wonder one you can play
just keep this on try to not allow him
to move the D pawn ever this may be a
rookie 6-year Pollard offers a draw okay
so let's check this um no deaf five
it's got D five maybe so let's start
with this move
nice could be six maybe
not super happy with this with what I
did here
wait-wait-wait-wait um no Knight f5 is
possible yeah it is possible
[Music]
wait what look you have to be kidding me
yeah come on yeah Gaiden take back and
play okay three
[Music]
I mean I am from what and that's the
last time I'm doing this stuff it's just
like yeah just like I want to show how
bad this position is even without the
blunder you know okay
so Luke takes his three is what he wants
to do to do this I guess
hmm that's a bit of bit a bit annoying
actually sorry I'm Roxy 294 yeah
[Music]
I can still not move any of his pieces
maybe we can go you can take a 98 at the
end
just needs to prevent him from from
getting out main danger is stumbling
into a night walk to be honest
King we walked him we walked to c7 if it
was Bishop d7 I take on b7 and he still
not has a move it also can also walk in
immediately right King r7
I know this one
for roopd aid
you sure cannot move it's made just made
and I'm not doing the take-backs anymore
I have to somehow set this up that it's
impossible simply to propose and so on
it's kind of awkward it just interrupts
the flow of the game completely like the
speck fourth bag for us whatever okay so
we had this a little bit weird opening
and maybe you should try to maybe you
can play some d5 now sometimes this is
possible I can't quite believe it yeah
and it cannot be enough compensation
yeah I tried to prevent him from winged
the D pawn but he can play d5 now that's
45 you can play now I cannot take it
home or that's same I can take it but
you get some compensation
especially kingside is not well
developed but he never reacted to
anything so just allowed me this oh this
is definitely good for white also just
retreating is good yeah that's that's
German 26 is weird but I wanted to get
to d6 with the noid unfortunately here
there is d5 so that doesn't help and
here I'm not sure about this phase of
the game if he had something better
Knight is 6 before f5 and now I had this
opportunity so yeah here okay for was
played but okay and now with hindsight
maybe there was something
you raise god rupee 394 no not no demons
are considered
Hey looks at looks okay right looks very
good I mean as long as this is um give
it what happened I went dam castles 94
look C 2 D 1 was was good okay this was
a bit annoying really oh I might be one
who wins everything
oh I had a stupid it wins everything
okay
and here it's not not super clear that
this is really so convincing
yeah the question is really like in this
if he somehow manages supposed to be
poor like as the engine suggests like
this it is still difficult to get get
things out like if you look at this it
still cannot move ob7
it's tough to say if black defenseless
the engine says zero but you never know
there could be there can be a situation
in something like that it could be a
situation where black is simply boxed in
and like I go f4 and run with the king
to c7 and that could be beyond the
machines horizon at the moment itself
say the state stays on zero zeros even
zero even with more depth yeah maybe
it's okay for like Jamie just felt this
felt really like it shouldn't work not
sure about taking actually but yeah I
took all the time here to completely box
him in
always feels good to have the King
participating in the attack yeah it's
it's a forced made already
yeah blackest move simply okay guys
thanks for watching